three to thirty years to the day it was
another first for Sky News if you look
up at the top you can see that 44
cameras in every corner of our newsroom
offering unprecedented access lifting
the lid on every decision we made every
story choice for one day only but for an
important reason why are you doing this
job
we decided today to let the cameras in
behind the scenes in our control rooms
and our meeting rooms in the newsroom to
talk to people and see how we work
because I feel very strongly that it's
important that news organizations are
transparent about the decisions they
take in Westminster we got to see the
challenges our correspondents face Liz
trusts chief secretary to the Treasury
he has finished all our politics we're
going to turn the tables on him and from
a man who was here from day one and
insight into just how things have
changed we were actually doing breaking
news first with the news all the time
and then as mobile phones have come
online as the internet happened most
people probably get their first glimmer
of a news story if they're following it
on the Internet so we have to make sure
that we can be first and accurate and
comprehensive in what we do thirty years
ago there was no Sky News radio from the
Star News Center at 4:00 or social media
we have to try to get rid of all that
mush and noise the nonsense that's on
social media and make sure that what we
broadcast is accurate news so in some
ways it's even more important what we do
now than it was before there was fake
news so this was a first seeing how the
news organization itself has transformed
been a newsroom was like different from
any way you've ever been before so
really just adapted to this fireman has
been really
from the key editorial meetings for
children who died in a house fire for
children including how he had to react
to breaking news Connor do you want to
oversee the person in opening our doors
and inviting the viewers in the channel
didn't know what would happen let's do
it just before Hatton Garden but this
was about demonstrating how Sky News
intends to go forward with openness and
with clarity
five seconds camera 10 next stand by the
double takes to start your move camera
turn Katie Spencer Sky News